now there's another great way you can
track down information about this if you
go back to the profiles tab you can
actually take a heap snapshot now what
the heap snapshot is going to do is
actually going to give you a listing of
everything that's been allocated up to
this snapshot in time of course this
really doesn't help you because it
actually lists a lot of system level
resources that have been allocated as
well what you need to do is actually
take a second heap snapshot now when you
take these two HAP snapshots you can
actually go down here to the bottom
where it says all objects and instead
set this to show objects allocated
between those two snapshots now this is
going to tell you only the objects that
were actually created in memory between
clicking that button now if you remember
before we showed that sawtooth pattern
inside of the timeline view which
basically told us that memory was being
allocated even though I was doing
nothing and with our two snapshots you
can see that same principle occurs here
that about 612 bytes were allocated
between the 3 seconds it took me to take
2 snapshots if we drill down into some
of the objects here you can see that a
bunch of numbers were actually created
most importantly you can see in the call
stack that these are X objects so it
looks like some velocity has been
changed right you can see velocity here
velocity dot X so somewhere in our
little application the X property of the
velocity object was actually created
clicking on the objects tab actually
shows us the same thing we can see an
object was created with a value of X and
a type of number for some sort of proto
object now playing around between a heap
timeline and heap snapshot gives you an
amazing amount of visibility into how
memory is being used in your web
application remember follow the memory
find your performance problems listen
you want to know more about performance
you want to get your application running
fast and smooth and jank free so that
your users don't have to complain about
it follow the tips I've detailed and
most importantly follow the perfmatters
hashtag on your favorite social media
network there's a lot of extremely smart
people out there all trying to handle
these problems in very important ways
following this hashtag is going to key
you in to what they're thinking and how
they're solving the problems